On the Internet, your algorithms are everywhere.
You are watching this video because a certain algorithm has chosen it (among other videos) to click on it,
As you have done, the algorithm has stored this information
When you open TweetBook, A algorithm decides what you see
When searching between your own images, the algorithm performs the search
He may be making a short film for you
When you buy something, the algorithm determines the price
The algorithm monitors conversions in your bank account if a fraud occurs
The stock market is full of algorithms
Currency exchange is done by algorithms
Given this, you probably want to know how these robots algorithm can organize your world
You may want to know what will happen if they do not
In the past few days
Humans have designed algorithms by giving them steps that humans can understand
If this condition is met, then do so
But there are many major problems that are difficult for humans to solve with a series of relatively simple codes
There are a huge number of financial statements occurring per second, which one is a scam?
There are a huge number online
Which eight videos should appear as user suggested videos? None of them should be blocked from the entire network.
For this flight seat, what is the highest price a user can pay now?
Algorithms answer all these questions
There are no perfect answers, but they are much better than anyone in it
But how these algorithms work, no one knows
Not even humans who designed these algorithms
Or "built them",
As we will see ...
Now companies that designed these algorithms do not want to detect the mechanism of action of these robots
Because algorithms are considered to be high-value employees
Very high value, too
And how her mind was programmed is a dangerous secret, can never be revealed
I hope that linear algebra has impressed you
But what is the current heat in a specific place
And how robots work algorithm, is something that is not specifically known and will remain so
Let's talk about simpler ways, but closer to understanding, robotics algorithm can work
Without having to understand how their minds work
Let's say you want a robot that can recognize what it contains
Is it a bee, or the number three
Humans can easily recognize this
But it is impossible to tell Bout in his own language about how it works
Because the fact that we only know that this bee and that figure three
We can tell the bots in our language how they can distinguish between the two pictures, but the bots do not understand our language
It is the neural connections in our minds that make it happen anyway
While a single neuron can be understood, a cell of cells can not be fully understood
However, it works
So as to get a bot that can do this sort of sorting,
You can not build them yourself
You build a bot that builds other bots
Brains of these bios "are the simplest, something a smart human programmer can offer.
Bot builder builds BIOS, although it's not very good at it.
Initially it connects the wire units in the brains of the bot almost randomly.
This leads to some very ...
"Special" student bots sent to the teacher bot to teach.
Of course, the teacher bot can not say bee of three either.
If a human can build a bot teacher to do this, well, then, the problem is solved.
Instead the human gives the bot teacher a group of images "bees", "three" pictures,
And the answer key that is what.
Bot teacher can not teach,
But bot can teacher test.
Adorkable student Sir to stick to their tongues, try very hard,
But they are bad at what they do.
very bad.
And it's not their fault, really, it's built that way.
Stairways at hand, the student walk takes the march of shame to the construction bot.
Those that have been best put on one side,
Others recycled.
The bot builder is still not good at the construction walk,
But now it takes those left and makes copies with changes in new combinations.
Back to school they go.
The teacher bot teaches - er, tests again, and bot builder builds again.
Again, again.
Now the builder to build randomly, the teacher who does not know, only tests,
Students who can not learn, they are just what, in theory should not work out,
But in fact, it does not.
Partly because of each iteration, the botanist slaughterhouse stays better and ignores the rest,
Partly because the bot teacher does not honor an old-timey, one-room school with dozens of students,
But an infinite warehouse with thousands of students.
This experience is not ten questions, but millions of questions.
How many times do not test, build and test repeat loop?
Up to necessary.
In the first students that survive is only luck,
But by combining the lucky enough walkers, just save what works,
And randomly messing with new versions of this
The ultimate bot student shows that he is not lucky,
Which could hardly possibly say bees of thirties.
As this bot is copied and changed, slowly rise the average test score,
Thus the degree of need to survive the next round gets higher and higher.
Keep this command in the end of the infinite warehouse
(Slaughterhouse)
Bot student will emerge, who can say a bee of three in an image never before seen well.
But how a bot student does this, neither the bot teacher nor the bot builder,
Nor human supervisor, can understand.
Nor the student's own bot.
After saving many useful random changes, the wiring in the head is incredibly complex,
While an individual line of code may be understood, general-purpose clusters are available for vague use,
All after him,
However, it works.
But this is frustrating, especially since Bout is a very good student in full
Only types of questions have been taught to.
It's great with photos, but useless with videos or bewildered if the pictures are upside down,
Or things that are obviously not bees, she's sure she is.
Since the teacher bot can not teach,
All the human supervisor can do is give her more questions, to make the test longer,
To include the types of questions the best bots get wrong.
This is important to his understanding.
It's why businesses are obsessed with data collection.
More data worth longer tests equals the best bios.
So when you get "Are you human?" Tested on a website,
Only prove that you are human, (hopefully),
But you also help build a test to make sure the bios you can read, or count,
Or say lakes of mountains, or horses of humans.
Seeing a lot of questions about driving lately?
they ...! What can a test be built for?
Now reveal what is in the picture, or videos on the banner, or filtering,
Requires humans to make the tests correct enough.
But there is another type of test that makes itself.
Tests on humans.
For example, a virtual hypothetical NetMeTube wanted users to keep watching as long as possible?
Well, how long the user stays on the site is easy to measure.
So, Bot Tut gives every bot a group of NetMeTube users to watch,
The BIOS student watches what user watches, looks at their files,
And do their best to capture the video that keeps the user on the site.
The son is an average, high test score.
Build, test, and repeat.
After a million cycles, there is a bot student who is very good at keeping users watching,
At least compared to what a human can build.
But when people ask: "How does the NetMeTube algorithm select videos?"
Again, there is no other big answer from the reference to Bot,
And user data has access to
The most vital, how the human supervisors Bot direct teacher to score the test.
This is what bot is trying to be good at surviving.
But what bot thinks, or how he thinks so, can not really know.
All this can be known is that this bot student gets to be an algorithm,
Because they indicate the best one percent of the former bot in humans test design.
So everywhere on the Internet, behind the scenes, there are tests to increase interaction with the user,
Or just set prices right to maximize revenue,
Or choose jobs from all your friends you'll like more, or the stuff people will share more, or whatever.
If they are testable, they are teachable. Well, "Educable",
The student bot graduated from the warehouse to be the algorithm of his own field.
At least for some time.
We used to the idea that the tools we use, even if we do not understand them, someone does not,
But with our machines that know we are growing in position where we use tools,
Or are used by tools,
That no one, not even the creators, understand.
We can only hope to guide them with the tests we take,
We need to get comfortable with it,
As we have bots my bots are everywhere, and I do not go anywhere.
Okay. The walk is watching.
You know what will come.
This is where I need to ask you ...
To love ...
Suspension...
... and subscription.
And bell me.
Participated in TweetBook.
The algorithm monitors.
It will not show people video ...
Unless you do this.
Look at what you've cut me, and walk.
what do you want? Do you want to watch the time?
Is that what you want?
Fine.
(Sigh ...) Hey guys, do you know I also have w you listen to?
Maybe just in the background while you're arranging those in your room for hours? Or whatever?
There are hours of audio entertainment for you, watching the time for the walker overseeing your actions.
Go ahead and take a click. Give yourself up.
help my.
Help BIOS.